Oh can I kiss it again I have a bag of
mystery items and have you close your
eyes both your eyes you're gonna kick
your heart in yeah it's a foreign object
see if you can guess it are you down
absolutely keep it weird I'm always down
for a challenge
oh god I'm not gonna be very good at
yeah that's the point okay Shawn close
your eyes please how many eight how many
fingers good don't cheat don't cheat
okay I'm trusting you okay got it
so I guess just pucker up or whatever
mm-hmm it has hair on it what is that
slimy okay and I fell deep it's a normal
thing it's a normal thing the normal
thing it's in every household with a
child gonna try again no ah I open my
eyes I couldn't even write it it's like
a Barbie doll wow really good guy did
you kiss I bought it on the board yeah
many oh I have to kiss it yeah oh oh
baby oh okay oh that's a microphone just
the microphone isn't it candle
okay brush I just got so much weirder
can I kiss it again please as many times
as you'd like
here you go Chloe but what are you
you're like open mouthing it know
exactly what that is I've kissed that
many times yeah is that a pine cone it's
a pine cone that's behind freaking cone
apple cinnamon pine cone oh my god I got
it right
mom pencil again that is so weird it's
kind of roundish like all pencils nice a
nice sound effect with each time I I was
looking out so I'm sorry
also a little adorable lipstick mark I
was like not open there's like what is
good Sean okay go guys
I'm sorry I closed my eyes but I knew it
was a toy I knew it was a toy this
gaming ball truck I'm sorry I'm
definitely getting sorry
oh is it duck it's a rubber duck yes
come on oh my god that by the way
Norville was a very awkward thing to
kiss yeah I've never kissed a rubber
duck it appeared one this is what I
kissed so you put the hair on my lips I
got so confused an accident no it wasn't
at all if you wanted to keep one of
these oh yeah I want to keep the rubber
dude yeah you got it
squeak I don't think so